welcome to the first session of genomics
data analysis where we are going to
discuss how we can process analyze and
interpret genomics data in general
so in today's session we will focus on
the core DNA code itself and we will
focus on how to interpret the variation
that is the main focus of analyzing
these genomics or these DNA code
themselves and what are the different
ways in which these variations can tell
us or can help us understand the biology
behind the subjects or biology behind
the study
samples that we are
uh investigating that we are studying so
let's start by going through a couple of
slides of review so if you already know
this you can speed it up or yeah I'll
follow it along so um let's start
reviewing the fundamentals of genomics
genomics is all about DNA so we know
that so let's let's also review what we
know about DNA code and what are the
answers that we can find inside the DNA
code and we also know that a DNA code is
uh
they comprises of huge sequences of
nucleotides that are stored in this DNA
and how do we make sense of these huge
number of sequences and and what do we
do to make sense of them what do we mean
by making sense of this DNA core right
so if we attribute the DNA code or
genomics data to a book then the code
can be thought as to be organized from
letters that will form sequences
sentences and the sentences will form
paragraphs and paragraphs or organism to
Chapters and understanding and knowing
how to read this code can help us
decipher the full story about who we are
can help us understand to look at our
history can also help us understand how
we as an organism or as a being are
connected to other living things that
are around us
so when we when we talk about genomics
the first thing that comes to our mind
is genes of course
these codes are genes are are the ones
that are passed from cell to cell and we
have proximately 3.2 billion letters in
total and these encodes to around 22
040s and these genes are made of made up
of biochemical entity called DNA which
is a short form for deoxyribose nucleic
acid this DNA molecule is a double helix
that is two long thin strands that are
twisted around each other like a spiral
stairways so in this DNA the backbone of
each strand is made up of sugar and
phosphate and these two strands will
interact with each other through
nucleotide bases that is what we
sequence
so as we spoke about that this DNA is
made up of nucleotides so the
nucleotides themselves are made up of
three important components the uh a
sugar ring that is called deoxyribose a
nitrogen containing base and the
phosphate group these nucleotides are
the ones that are joined to one another
in a chain by covalent bonds that form
between the sugar molecule of one
nucleotide and the phosphate group of
the next this result in an alternate
sugar phosphate backbone and the
nucleotides of the two complementary
strands are connected towards uh or
connected together
and this connection that connects two
nucleotides of the complete sand is
called base pairing or base pairs the
base pairing connects these two strands
of DNA and this connection gives to the
characteristics double helix form of the
DNA
so in this example in this structure we
can see that the adenine is always bound
to thiamine and the guanine is always
bound to cytosine and they form the four
bases of the nucleotide atgn C
so that's a very short introduction
about the DNA a very DNA and its Basics
so let's look into various ways where we
can spot the DNA variation and how can
those be helpful for us in understanding
the biology behind this
so we spoke about this and uh
what do we mean by studying the DNA
variation when we when we discuss about
studying DNA variation we always want to
compare the sequences that we have in
the current sample that we uh that we
are
that to the reference sequence and to
identify what are the places in which
the sequences or the bases vary or bases
differ generally so that this
differences in the basis or this
differences in the nucleotides or these
differences in the in this DNA code can
give rise to
um
unwanted ethics which we call as
mutations are typically they are termed
as DNA variants right when these
variations affect the end product which
could be a protein coded by the specific
Gene then we will call this variance as
mutation we will speak about this little
bit later and depending upon what type
of variant that we are getting the end
product the mute the protein can be
altered uh in the sequence and that
alteration can affect the functionality
of the protein and hence we are ending
up with a
pathogenic variant that is termed as
mutation
the reference sequence where do they
come from so this reference sequence
actually comes from the first human
genome projects it which is what enabled
us to compare any given DNA sequence
from a human to a common reference this
common reference is what is compiled
from
multiple individuals
T and this project is a 13 year long
project which started at 1990 and we all
know about what this project gave us uh
gave us a till date so the primary goals
of this Human Genome Project was first
to determine the DNA sequence and the
location of the estimated genes the
estimated number of genes at that time
was around 100 000 but now we have
filtered that and we have come to a
consensus that there are around 21 000
to 22 000 genes in our whole genome and
all the other sequences are present to
regulate the
translation of these genes into proteins
most of the other sequences so this is
the reference sequence to which we will
compare any new sequence that we will
see any new sequence that we will
generate and and identify the
differences in the sequences and try to
characterize the differences in the
sequences which in a nutshell can be
termed as genomics data analysis
so this
resulted or with the advancement in the
Next Generation sequencing technology we
have now actually uh obtained or there
is an ever increasing number of genomes
that are sequenced
uh
and uh the cost of the sequences have
drastically decreased and this gives
rise to more number of sequences being
generated and we in the end are ending
up with more and more data that has been
deposited to public repositories like
ncbi and ebi and we can make use of all
these public repositories to
make meaningful data analysis and
understand the genomic variations that
are present in the samples in general
so
this plot indicates that
the decrease in the cost of genomics
Technology generally followed Moore's
Law until one point and after that it
drastically reduces and uh which can
actually give you or which can actually
give you an indication of how the
technology has actual technology
genomics technology has
um
improved leaps and bowels so what do I
mean by understanding the differences we
already spoke about that a little bit
more background for this
um
efforts such as the one described in the
previous slide variety of different uh
uh I mean numerous different studies
that will try to understand uh variances
or variations that in the genomics code
compared to the reference code it can be
uh can now for example detect
um harmless and also harmful variances
um
present in the as present in the
sequences that we are actually
sequencing just like just like
any code or just like any any sequence
of letters we can expect the DNA to
contain mistakes and these mistakes
actually occur as a result of copying
the DNA Source too many times and and
also these mistakes can also occur as a
result of various stresses that are that
the cells will undergo and these
stresses and the result of copying may
actually interfere with the copying
mechanism of the DNA and can introduce
mistakes and these mistakes are the one
that we are focused on detecting and
when these mistakes actually occur in
important regions like genes that will
encode very important proteins and even
the inside the genes important stretches
of sequences that are that result in key
changes in the proteins
that will end up altering the shape and
size of the protein and it can also end
up altering the shape and size of the
cell as it is given here ah can actually
lead to serious issues when that Gene is
being produced this is expertly
understood in the event of sickle cell
anemia where a normal protein sequence
encoded by the gene actually produces
red blood cells of a normal morphology
and when one single nucleotide change
actually changes the amino acid from
glutamide to Valley and that results in
producing red blood cells that shape
like sickles and result in reduced
carrying capability of oxygen and hence
it results in anemia so this is one of
the example of mutation or point
mutation uh one of the examples of
mutation that occurs in single
nucleotide position and all the
mutations that occurs in single
nucleotide positions are actually
defined as point mutations depending
upon what is being changed there are
several
um
types of point mutations that one can
characterize so one among those is
substitution mutation a substitution
mutation can cause several consequences
to the DNA code but this substitution
mutation implies minimal change that
only leads to single nucleotide change
as we actually discussed so what is
changed
one nucleotide that is in the reference
sequence is substituted by another
nucleotide and this resulting
substitution mutation may or may not end
up changing the amino acid sequence that
the tri-nucleotide codon codes for and
there are also other forms of single or
point mutation uh which could actually
involve insertion of a single nucleotide
into a position in the altered uh sample
sequence compared to the reference
sequence this insertion unlike the
substitution mutation may end up
changing the reading frame and that that
encodes a tri-nucleotide codon and hence
from the point where the insertion is
observed the resulting protein sequence
may be completely different from the one
that is present in the wild type or the
reference genome and this may result in
A protein that may not function properly
and or that may prematurely end and
contrary or complementary to the
insertion mutation we also have deletion
mutation where one nucleotide from the
from the sample sequence compared to the
reference sequence is deleted just as an
insertion mutation this bellation
mutation will actually change the
reading frame of the trinucleotide codon
which produces amino acid sequences and
hence it results in the protein
sequences that is completely different
from the wild type variant and this may
also or this is also most likely
expected to change the functionality of
the protein and cause serious defects in
the cells uh functioning and um
General cellular molecular function so
uh unlike substitution mutation
insertion or deletion may actually
um contain more than one number of
mutation one number of nucleotide and
again in those instances the resulting
protein May completely differ and there
is another form of variation or another
form of mutation that is duplication
which consists of a piece of DNA that is
abnormally copied more than one or more
times in different places or in a
adjacent adjacent location this type of
mutation again May alter the
functionality of the resulting protein
and some of the examples of these
mutation we will discuss in detail later
foreign
so depending we spoke about uh point
mutation and focusing on the types of
mutation from the point of view of the
amino acid sequence that these mutation
encodes for we can again categorize this
mutation into missions nonsense and
frame shift mutation so a missense
mutation is characterized by the change
of uh point mutation of the nucleotide
level that result in the changes in the
amino acid um changes in amino acid
sequences right sometimes at this single
amino acid change that occurs in the
protein may occur at a structural or
functionally important location and may
end up being greatly changing the
proteins functions so in that event as
we spoke about as we discussed the end
result may actually completely change
the function of the protein and hence
affect the
um
functioning proper functioning of the
cell completely different
so a nonsense mutation is actually uh is
actually a change in the nucleotide base
change of the nucleotide base
prematurely stops the protein production
by introducing a stop codon at that
specific position so this definitely
changes not only the protein sequence
sequence themselves but it stops the
protein sequence production prematurely
and results in a shortened length of the
proteins with themselves so this can
result in the protein folding
incorrectly or not folding at all and
hence the functionality of the protein
is completely lost a frame shift
mutation is what results in when we have
an insertion or a deletion as we already
discussed and this changes the frame
which reads the tri-nucleotide codon
that encodes for different amino acid
sequences and hence the since the
reading frame is changed by the
insertion of this one adenine at this
position
now whatever is
encoded after that insertion position or
after that specific point mutation or
completely is is completely changed and
this again will result in a protein
sequence that is different from the wild
type and this deferred or this
mutated protein sequence May again
result in incorrect folding or result in
a completely different function than
what the original protein is intended
for all these will actually affect the
cell's functionality to a larger extent
and depending upon what is
where this
changes occur in in the morphology of
the tissues and and how they actually
occur and how they actually affect the
cell and tissues and hence organism they
can be uh characterized into genetic
variation compared to mutation so
generally
all the changes that we observe in our
sample compared to the reference
sequences are termed as genetic
variations or genetic variants so the
genomics data analysis focuses on
identifying these lists of genetic
variations and characterizing annotating
them into potentially harmful and
potentially
not very harmful and that the one that
can be ignored by just characterizing
them to um
to a different level so for example if
you see the morphology of this for
example in this example we have a wild
type
form which at in its natural form
without any mutation has this specific
morphology and that could be some
variations in their genetic Gene
sequences that can change for example
the eye color that can give a couple of
more modifications to the morphology but
if these mutations are no not mutation
if these variations are not going to
change the functionality are not going
to affect the survivability of that
specific form or organism they are not
termed as mutation they are generally
considered as genetic variance or
polymorphism etcetera but
mutate variance that results in loss of
function that results in improper
function that can cause diseases or that
can cause genetic defects are termed as
pathogenic or pathogenic and hence they
are called as pathogenic mutations
sometimes in several of the publication
this the word mutation and variants are
actually used
interchangeably but generally when you
refer to a mutation we always refer to
the pathogenic version of the behavior
and when you refer to variance we either
refer to changes in the nucleotide
sequences that are and that are
not characterized as of now or as of at
the moment of data analysis or they are
characterized to be
um
inconsequential to the functionality of
the tissue or organism so that is that
is the difference in uh
that is the difference in their
terminology that we have to keep uh keep
our mind
so as we as we spoke about uh how do we
identify these genomic variations right
these genomic variations can be
identified by subjecting the samples
into high throughput sequencing or next
Generation sequencing which you will
learn a lot in the upcoming
in the upcoming sessions and when we map
all these leads to specific position in
the genome or reference genome then we
can identify uh the places or the
positions in which that specific
nucleotide is changed or that
specifically nucleotide is converted
into a variant or a mutant form when
when we speak about single nucleotide
variant so when we speak about the
genomic variation that we are trying to
characterize uh let's refresh our memory
that what we have been discussing and
summarize into four or five points so ah
single nucleotide variant or SNB in
short
um
uh can be characterized as a single
nucleotide change that may or may not be
present in whole or most of the
population basically this means any
change that we observe in our sample uh
from uh the reference genome
um is uh
can be termed as s and V or single
nucleotide variations
while a very uh another term that we
always
hear or but we always discuss is single
nucleotide polymorphism for example when
we have samples that typically
consist or comprises of more than one
percentage of the population or more
than for example not more than one
person not more than one percentage of
the population and when we observe this
specific variant in more than one
percentage of the population and that
variant is considered to be single
nucleotide polymorphism so when we refer
to this one percentage that refers to
the whole population set of that
specific
group of sample
that it refers to not the sample
themselves so now you can uh now you can
for example
appreciate the amount of sequencing that
has to go into estimating the one
percentage change of variant variant
that is presented in one percentage of
the whole of the population to turn them
as SNP for example the snps that are
characterized for the ethnic group and
race race different races like
Caucasians different places like uh
Asians and uh Europeans they actually
involved in sequencing more than one
percentage or approximating to
sequencing more than one percentage of
the population to identify these single
nucleotide polymorphisms for that
specific group of samples
or population so
any variant that we find uh to occur
above the level of technical error is
can be termed as single nucleotide
variant and any single nucleotide
variant that is prevalent in
approximately one percentage of the
population can be termed as single
nucleotide polymorphism and another type
of variation that we often refer to is
the copy number variation where a gene
is encoded in multiple copies in our
genome but the number of the copies
varies between different samples and
between different sequences and when
this number of copies actually varies
significantly between the reference
sequences and our sample sequences then
that may also result in the result in
the diff result in the diff result in uh
result in the changed level of gene
expression and hence
may actually result in Altered uh
phenotypical condition of the cell or
tissue or organism engine so
all these changes that are characterized
at the level of the genes or genome are
termed towards genotype and many of
these genotype can actually
end up in a specific phenotype that can
be harmful or that can be harmless or
that can be potentially
ignorant or potentially
beneficial itself in some aspect for
example in this specific Gene one of the
examples of harmful mutation or harmful
genotype is the one that involves tax
genes in this specific example pack 6 is
a gene that will encode for tactics
protein and it has been
characterized and recognized that this
tax family of genes is necessary for the
development of eye in in almost all of
the organisms and surprisingly
the development of I in many of the
organisms follow similar developmental
path so we can follow or follow the
progression of uh this um this Gene and
their defects in many different model
organisms and experiments in such
organisms like mouse or mice samples
demonstrate that deficiency in path six
will lead to not only in decrease in the
brain structure normal normalcy or
normality that leads to autism it can
also lack uh uh complete formation of
Iris or you can result
in cornea and that will end up causing
blindness in the
um
yeah blindness in the variant or the
phenotype the blindness as part of the
you know type this is one of the
examples of harmful mutation there are a
couple of examples of potentially
harmless variants for example some
mutation in in specific Gene can cause a
long hair growth in in eyebrows or in
eyelashes they can be potentially a
little bit difficult to deal with but
they are not harmful in any case one
more example of for example potentially
um not very harmful but um
uh advantages mutation variant is the
SNP that is linked to or linked with the
development of blue eyes for the
Caucasian is is uh the variant that is
linked to the blue eye of Caucasian is
actually an SMP that is characterized
for uh
European and uh us uh race people so
these are all different ways and
different forms of variants uh that can
or not uh
may not end up in causing difference in
the phenotypical versions of the samples
so
such analysis to understand and
characterize these variants can be
performed at many different levels to
investigate the functions of variety of
different genes in multiple different
research areas right these research
areas can include drug metabolism by
studying the enzyme function that
by studying the enzyme function that is
key in the
um
catalysis and the key in the
functionality of specific metabolite and
this can also end up trying to
characterize we can also end up trying
to characterize mutations in specific
genes that can cause tumor in that case
um genes that are linked with tumor
progression and tumerogenesis and we
already spoke about sickle cell anemia
this in case this um in this example is
uh
now it is high by the effects of
germline mutations that are inherited uh
from uh from our parents so furthermore
one can also use uh use genomics to
explore pathogens and to understand uh
important properties of their pathogens
as a result of their or as the function
of their genomic variants to study
virulence to study disease transmission
and to study drug resistance etc etc